m
[Musique]
dans le cadre du salon de l'agriculture
la boutique de la réunion du département
situé rue du renard à paris a invité ses
fidèles clients à déguster les produits
proposés sur le village de la réunion au
salon de l'agriculture
l'objectif en fait c'est de défaire
découvrir en avant première les produits
qui sont exposés au sein du futur à nous
plus fidèles clients de la boutique et
le but c'est de permettre à ces
personnes aussi de venir au sein de la
culture avec des billets qui sont qui
nous conte une offre à chacun d'entre
eux qui font de passage ici voilà un
moment de partage et de convivialité
pour permettre aux réunionnais de la
métropole de retrouver les produits de
leur hymne je crois que c'est important
qu'on puisse rayonner à l'échelle de la
france de la métropole et je crois que
c'était aussi cette occasion le salon de
l'agriculture pour leur dire combien on
compte sur leur présence pour venir tout
simplement retrouver les goûts les
odeurs les senteurs de l'île de la
réunion et puis pour les aider leur dire
qu'on les oublie pas qu on est toujours
à leurs côtés et qui ont éventuellement
s'ils peuvent s'ils ont besoin de nous
on pourrait toujours répondre à leurs
sollicitations
à l'antenne du département ici à paris
dans beaucoup de réunionnais
métropolitain qui résident dans
l'hexagone et qui ont à coeur
aujourd'hui leur arrivée un peu cette
flamme qu'ils ont en eux à savoir donc à
certains mal du pays nostalgie lle
effectivement donc à la réunion générale
et les produits agricoles aujourd'hui et
notamment 7 s'est produit que nous
mettons en valeur tend à mettre en avant
tout cette spécificité cette culture qui
est la nôtre
une initiative très appréciée par les
150 personnes venues ce jour non
franchement très très bien ç'a permis de
faire découvrir des choses qu'on n'a pas
forcément ici qu'on trouve pas dans le
commerce
donc il faut absolument rentrer en
vacances pour pouvoir pour pouvoir les
découvrir donc avec avec le
le magasin c'est une très bonne
initiative
et puis ça permet de faire découvrir
plein de choses même pas forcément
réunionnais mais même aux métropolitains
qui souhaitent découvrir la réunion
son ton suter a pu repartir avec son
ticket d'entrée pour découvrir les 600
m² dédiés à l'île de la réunion au salon
de l'agriculture
[Musique]